große wende im fall madeleine mccann im
zusammenhang mit dem verschwinden des
dreijährigen britischen mädchens medien
besser kennen am dritten mai 2007 aus
einer appartementanlage in drei lose in
portugal ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig gegen
einen 43 jährigen deutschen
staatsangehörigen wegen des verdachts
des mordes
daraus können sie annehmen dass wir
davon ausgehen dass das mädchen tot ist
red lane ist seit 13 jahren spurlos
verschwunden
die familie mccann machte gemeinsam mit
freunden an der portugiesischen algarve
urlaub in diesem zusammenhang wird auch
nach zwei autos gesucht die der
verdächtige benutzt haben soll
ihre eltern hatten die hoffnung nie
aufgegeben dass maddie noch lebend
gefunden wird aber sie seien realistisch
teilte ihr sprecher mit
was eine gänsehaut meldung
das wahrgenommen haben ich würde meine
kinder niemals im hotelzimmer allein
lassen ich dass ich habe das schon oft
gemacht aber mit einem babyfon also ich
habe ich jetzt auch nicht getraut die
jetzt völlig mb von hat mich aber dabei
alt waren wieder
na ja bestimmt babyalter vielleicht habe
ich schon mit begonnen also dass wir
noch einen drink an der bar und oder so
im urlaub aber man hat irgendwie dieser
glaube die welt ist eine gute unter
passiert schon nicht hat man mit dem
fall maddie verloren
man hatte immer im hinterkopf mein kind
könnte geklaut werden selbst ich wohne
im erdgeschoss setzt jetzt denke ich ich
lasse das fenster nicht gekippt gibt
mein kind könnte ja mitgenommen werden
und das hat alles dieser fall maddie mit
uns gemacht und wie sehr habe mit den
eltern mitgelitten die diese suche
niemals aufgegeben haben kein mensch hat
mir geglaubt dass irgendwann ein täter
gefunden wird ja ich finde es auch
wahnsinn dass das endlich hier zum
schluss gekommen ist jemand schlimmste
die eltern dass das kind die eigentlich
tot ist leider aber es natürlich
irgendwann der erleichterung zu wissen
man kann jetzt abschließen auch damit
nicht es ist ja wahnsinn 13 jahre sein
kind zu suchen und zu hoffen und zu
sitzen das ist doch also das ist
wahnsinn finde ich ich hätte diese
wendung ehrlich gesagt auch nie für
möglich gehalten ich habe nicht sogar
zwischendurch möchte ich offen zugeben
teilweise dabei erwischt dass ich immer
dachte ja wer war ist denn jetzt
und wenn ich mir so mich daran
zurückerinnern auch mit was zu
schlagzeilen die eltern konfrontiert
waren war als sie selber zielscheibe
waren also ich muss auch ganz ehrlich
sagen auch wenn das grausam klingt weil
jetzt ist sozusagen der tod gewiß aber
ich glaube dass diese gewissheit
vielleicht besser erträglich ist als sie
ein leben lang zu suchen richtig aber
auch mit diesem gefühl zu leben dass man
selber beschuldigt ist ein eigenes kind
irgendwie es angetan zu haben nicht und
die sind ja selber auf der suche gewesen
nach dem kind also das ist nicht einfach
zu ertragen auch in einem in einer
gemeinschaft dann weiter zulegen in
einer ehe weiter zu leben wo der partner
eventuell auch beschuldigt wird und dann
guckt oder partner vielleicht doch mal
mit anderen augen an oder war also das
also dass ein zustand das ist unfassbar
aber chapeau an die ermittler dass sie
das herausgefunden dass sie dran
geblieben so genau daran gegeben dass
man niemals aufgeben wirklich es ist
wirklich wahr
[Musik]